>>> IT'S THE WORST QUESTION I'VE
EVER HEARD.
>> ARE YOU ACTUALLY RECORDING?
>> I'M ACTUALLY LIVE!
♪
>>> WELL, WELL, WELL, HELLO
MEDIA, THE SAME MEDIA THAT
RANKED ME LAST QUARTERBACK IN MY
DRAFT CLASS.
THE SAME MEDIA THAT SAID I
WASN'T A QUARTERBACK.
IT WASN'T JUST BILL PULLIAM.
YOU ALL THOUGHT IT.
WAS JOSH ROSEN LEADING A
GAME-WINNING DRIVE ON MONDAY
NIGHT FOOTBALL LAST NIGHT.
DO MOST RUNNING BACKS THROW FOR
442 YARDS?
I WILL NO LONGER BE DISRESPECTED
BECAUSE THIS RAVEN, NEVERMORE.
TRY TO COME AT ME.
OUR ONLY LOSS THIS SEASON WAS TO
THE RAIDERS AND I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING THE NEWS,
BUT I GOT MY REVENGE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I AM THE LAMAR JACKSON AND I AM
NOT AFRAID TO DIE.
ASK YOUR QUESTIONS.
I WILL DESTROY THE ANSWERS.
>> LAMAR!
LAMAR!
>> YES, SIR.
>> LET'S GET THIS KICKED OFF.
YOU THERE ON THE LEFT.
>> HEY, THIS IS DOLLA B. TOO.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY TO THE
LAMAR HATERS?
>> DOLLA B. TOO, I HAVE TO SAY
TO ALL OF THE LAMAR HATERS LOOK
I SAY TO ANY INDIVIDUAL LAMAR
HATER, YOU DO NOT KNOW YOURSELF
FOR I AM LAMAR JACKSON,
GREATNESS EMBODIED IN A HUMAN
AND TO HATE LAMAR JACKSON IS TO
HATE YOURSELF.
SEEK HELP DOLLA B. TOO.
NEXT QUESTION.
YOU THERE.
>> HEY, THIS IS CAMP DADDY.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THIS IS THE
MOST POINTLESS SHIT EVER.
>> HELLO, CAMP DADDY.
IT SEEMS FATE HAS BROUGHT US TWO
TOGETHER TO ASK THESE DEEP
QUESTIONS OF EXISTENCE, SUCH AS
A QUESTION THAT ISN'T REALLY A
QUESTION, BUT MORE A STATEMENT.
GOOD.
WELL, CAMP DADDY.
MEET YOUR FATE OR RATHER A
MIRRORED VERSION OF YOURSELF.
WE ARE ALL CONNECTED IN THIS ONE
THING AND AS YOU ARE DOING
SOMETHING POINTLESS, I AM DOING
SOMETHING POINTFUL.
BE THE LAMAR JACKSON ON OUR WAY
TO GREATNESS.
>> WE ARE ALL WITNESSING
SOMETHING THAT HAS NEVER
HAPPENED BEFORE AND CAMP DADDY,
I AM SO GLAD THAT FATE BROUGHT
US TOGETHER FOR THIS MOMENT.
YOUR FATE WAS TO ASK THIS, AND
MINE IS TO BE THE GREATEST
QUARTERBACK IN THE NFL.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> LAMAR!
EXCUSE ME, LAMAR!
>> GO AHEAD.
>> HEY, LAMAR.
THIS IS SAGE CASTRO.
WAS THAT BACK SORENESS EARLIER
THIS YEAR FROM CARRYING THE
TEAM?
>> HELLO, SAGE CASTRO.
VERY COMPLEX QUESTION WITH A
COMPLEX ANSWER.
MAYBE.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> LAMAR!
>> OVER HERE!
>> YOU IN FRONT.
>> HEY, LAMAR, THIS IS TIME IS
KEY 7.
ARE YOU A RUNNING BACK?
>> TIME IS KEY 7, NO, I'M NOT A
RUNNING BACK.
IN FACT, I HATE RUNNING BACKS SO
MUCH THAT I HAD ALL OURS INJURED
IN THE PRE-SEASON, LATAVIUS, YOU
BETTER WATCH OUT AND I'LL DO IT
AGAIN AND I'M ONLY GOING TO PASS
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE TO SPITE
YOU, TIME IS KEY 7.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I'M GOING
TO HACK INTO THE BLEACHER REPORT
SERVICE, AND I'LL LOOK UP YOUR
I.P. ADDRESS.
I'M GOING DRIVE TO YOUR HOME,
CHATTANOOGA, TENNESSEE.
I'M GOING TO DRIVE TO
CHATTANOOGA ON THE WAY TO MY
CAR.
AND THE TOYOTA ECHO.
AND GO TO YOUR PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT AND PROBABLY AT A
JAMBA JUICE OR WHATEVER.
I'M GOING TO GO TO THAT JAMBA
JUICE AND I'LL SAY, HE'S NOT A
CASHIER.
HE'S ACTUALLY A RUNNING BACK,
AND I'LL KEEP REPEATING IT.
I'LL JUST SAY IT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
HE'S A RUNNING BACK.
TIME IS KEY 7 IS A RUNNING BACK,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
ALL OF THE OTHER CUSTOMERS AT
THAT JAMBA JUICE WILL SAY WELL,
HE MUST BE A RUNNING BACK
BECAUSE LAMAR JACKSON ONLY
SPEAKS TRUTH AND THEY WILL NO
LONGER TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY AS A
CASHIER, AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT, YOU WILL GO BROKE,
TIME IS KEY 7 AND THEN YOU WILL
DIE ALONE NEXT QUESTION.
>> HEY, LAMAR, THIS IS WILL
EASY.
DO YOU THINK YOU DESERVE TO BE
IN THE MVP CONVERSATION IN.
>> WILL EASY, THIS IS AN EASY
QUESTION.
I ALWAYS DESERVE TO BE IN THE
MVP CONVERSATION.
I'VE DONE SOMETHING THAT MOST
PEOPLE HAVEN'T IN THE NFL CAREER
AND THAT'S TO WIN AN MVP IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
NOW LAST YEAR, I GAVE AARON
RODGERS A GIFT.
HE'S ELDERLY AND WE SHOULD
RESPECT OUR ELDERS.
WHO IS MY COMPETITION THIS YEAR.
KYLER MURRAY.
I'VE GOT MY GOOD FRIEND JUSTIN
TUCKER WHO WILL PUNT TO THE
MOON.
JOSH ALLEN AND THAT'S A GANGLY
DUDE THAT'S WAY TOO GOOFY TO DO
WHAT IT TAKES TO TURN MVP AND WE
HAVE TO SERVE FOR BROKE FOR THE
CHARGERS AND ALL OF THAT AND GO
AHEAD AND ASK WHAT YOUR MOM
THINKS ABOUT JUSTIN HERBERT.
SHE'LL BE, LIKE, JUSTIN HERBERT.
IS THAT SOMEONE YOU WENT TO
GRADE SCHOOL WITH?
HE'S SO RESPECTABLE, BUT IF YOU
ASK HIM ABOUT THE LAMAR JACKSON,
SHE'LL KNOW THE ANSWER AND SHE
WILL RESPOND.
OH, LAMAR JACKSON WHO WILL BE
UTTERED IN THE MOST DEFERENTIAL
WAY, THAT'S THE ELITE
QUARTERBACK OF THE BALTIMORE
FOOTBALL RAVENS.
THAT IS AN MVP-CALIBER CANDIDATE
WORTHY OF BEING IN THE MVP
CONVERSATION.
NEXT QUESTION!
>> LAMAR!
LAMAR!
>> GO AHEAD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS BROOKLYN IN 10.
DO YOU MISS MARK INGRAM?
>> MARK INGRAM, THAT IS A
SOULFUL BROTHER WHO HAS NOW GONE
ON TO WHERE ALL OF THE GREAT
BACKS IN THE LEAGUE GO TO RUN
OUT THEIR DAYS IN THE GREAT FARM
I CALL THE HOUSTON TEXANS WHERE
YOU WILL DUKE IT OUT IN WHAT
WILL AMOUNT TO MEANINGLESS,
MEANINGLESS GAINS FOR DOING WHAT
YOU LOVE AND MARK INGRAM, I SAY
THIS WITH ALL OF THE LOVE IN MY
HEART.
I GOT YOU.
NOW YOU'RE PLAYING WITH REX
BURKHEAD AND RUNNING AROUND WITH
ALL OF THEM OTHER RBs IN THE
TEAM GOING NOWHERE FAST AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT, ONCE A RAVEN
ALWAYS A RAVEN, CACAW, CACAW.
>> YOU THERE ON THE LEFT.
>> HEY, LAMAR, THIS IS WHY NOT
WIN.
>> WHAT'S UP, WHY NOT WIN?
>>.
>> DID YOU EVER ADMIT THAT YOUR
KRAFRMS WE
CRAMPS WERE A CASE OF THE POOPS?
>> WHY NOT WIN, I SHOULD GET IT
TATTOOED ON THE BIG OLD FOOTBALL
THAT'S ALREADY ON MY CHEST.
CRAMP, A CASE OF THE POOPS,
THESE ARE BOTH THINGS THAT LAMAR
JACKSON HAS TO SUFFER AS BEING
PART OF A HUMAN BEING AND TO BE
FRANK WITH YOU, I CANNOT TELL
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THESE TWO
BODILY MOVEMENTS, OKAY?
THEY'RE REALLY THE SAME TO ME.
CRAMPS, POOPS, THEY'RE THE SAME.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I CALL
CRAMPS POOPS -- I CALL NUMBER
TWOs NUMBER EIGHTS BECAUSE NO
MATTER WHAT LAMAR JACKSON DOES
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
I ENCOURAGE YOU, WHY NOT WIN, IN
YOUR LIFE TO SAY THAT WHEN
YOU'RE GOING TO DO A NUMBER
EIGHT, THEN YOU'RE DOING A LAMAR
JACKSON.
I ATE TOO MUCH TACO BELL AND I'M
GOING TO DO A LAMAR JACKSON
LATER AND THAT'S A NOBLE THING
YOU'RE TAKING ON.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> OKAY.
I SEE YOU.
YOU THERE ON THE LEFT.
>> HI, MR. JACKSON, THIS IS
RESNAK 11, CAN YOU BE MY DAD?
>> RESNAK 11, THIS IS AN
IMPLICITLY SAD QUESTION WITH
HOPEFULLY A JUBILANT REPLY.
RESNAK 11 I'M ALREADY YOUR DAD.
NEXT QUESTION?
>> LAMAR!
LAMAR!
>> YEAH, GO AHEAD, YOU THERE ON
THE RIGHT.
>> HELLO, LAMAR, THIS IS PASS
TWO DEAD ITALIANS.
WHO IS WINNING A FIGHT BETWEEN
FAJI YOSHGS.
>> IT'S VAGUELY INSENSITIVE AT
BEST AND AT WORST.
>> HARBAUGH, I'VE SEEN HARBAUGH
UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL AND NOT A
LOT THAT WILL PUT ME IN BETWEEN
ONE OF HIS FIST AND A FACE, NOT
GOING TO DO IT.
HE'S SURVIVED GROWING UP IN
HOUSE HARBAUGH WITH JIM
HARBAUGH.
ANYBODY WHO HAS SURVIVED THAT,
THEY'VE GOT GOD'S FAVOR BEHIND
THEM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL SAY FAJIO,
HE'S OLD AND GETTING UP THERE IN
AGE AND I WOULD TELL YOU WE'RE
DOING FAJIO A FAVOR AND LET'S
JUST GO AHEAD AND GET HIM OVER
THE FINISH LINE AND SEND HIM
OVER TO HEAVEN AND HE COULD BE
REUNITED WITH THE ANCESTORS AND
THE GREATS THAT HAVE GONE BEFORE
HIM AND THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
PASS TWO ITALIANS.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> GO AHEAD, YOU THERE ON THE
LEFT.
>> LAMAR, THIS IS DWAYNE YOUNG.
ARE YOU FAST OR IS EVERYONE
SLOW?
>> DWAYNE YOUNG -- THESE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT KEEPS LAMAR
JACKSON UP AT NIGHT.
QUESTIONING THE RULES OF THIS
UNIVERSE AND THE PHYSICS THAT
BOUND US ALL.
AM I FAST OR IS EVERYONE SLOW?
DWAYNE YOUNG, I DON'T THINK THIS
IS EITHER/OR.
THESE ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
EVENTS IN OUR UNIVERSE, DWAYNE
YOUNG.
LAMAR JACKSON IS THE EPITOME OF
FAST AND AT THE SAME TIME
EVERYONE IS SLOW.
LAMAR JACKSON FAST, EVERYONE IS
SLOW.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, YOU LOOK UP
THE DEFINITION OF FAST YOU WILL
SEE MY FACE.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> EXCUSE ME, LAMAR.
>> GO AHEAD.
YOU THERE ON THE RIGHT.
>> HELLO, LAMAR, THIS IS NOT
JOHN MORANT.
DO YOU THINK YOU HAVE BETTER
HANDS THAN HOLLYWOOD BROWN.
>> NOT JOHN MORANT.
THIS IS AGAIN, A QUESTION,
QUESTIONING THE RULES OF NATURE.
>> NOW BETTER HANDS THAN
HOLLYWOOD BROWN.
HE'S GOT GREAT HANDS.
I'VE GOT GREAT HANDS AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE BOTH GOOD AT OUR
CRAFTS.
NOW I CAN'T POSSIBLY ANSWER THIS
QUESTION IN SUB-TEN YEARS AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S ASKED
BY SCIENTISTS AND SOMETHING MUCH
CLOSER TO QUESTIONING IS WHETHER
JOHN LENNON HAS BETTER HANDS
OUTSIDE OF PAUL McCARTNEY
BECAUSE THOSE TWO GENTLEMEN ON
THE BEATLES MADE AMAZING MUSIC.
HAVE YOU HEARD THE BEATLES
ANTHOLOGY?
HAVE YOU HEARD "YELLOW
SUBMARINE" MY GOD!
WE ARE BLESSED TO BE ON THE SAME
TIME LINE AS THOSE GENTLEMEN.
I WILL TACK JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION AFTER THIS, JUST ONE
MORE.
BETTER BE A GOOD BEEN.
THESE HAVE BEEN GREAT SO FAR.
GO AHEAD.
>> HEY, LAMAR THS, THIS IS BUCK
614.
WILL YOU BE IN THE PLAYOFFS THIS
YEAR?
>> BUCKEYE 614, I'M GOING TO
SHOW UP IN THE PLAYOFFS JUST
LIKE I ALWAYS SHOW UP.
I'M GOING TO BE THERE, CLEATED
UP, SHOELACES TIED, TATTED
CHEST, THROWING THE GREATEST
GAMES THAT ANYONE HAS EVER
WITNESSED AND THAT'S NOT ALL
THAT I'M GOING TO SHOW UP.
I'M GOING TO SHOW UP IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND I'LL SHOW UP IN THE
REGULAR SEASON AND I'M GOING
SHOW UP IN THE POSTSEASON.
I'M GOING SHOW UP IN YOUR
DREAMS.
I'M GOING TO SHOW UP IN YOUR
NIGHTMARES.
I'M GOING SHOW UP WHEN YOUR EYES
ARE OPEN, AND I'M GOING TO SHOW
UP WHEN YOUR EYELIDS ARE CLOSED
BECAUSE I AM OMNIPRESENT.
BEHOLD, GREATNESS EMBODIED IN
THE LAMAR JACKSON BUCKEYE 614.
THAT'S ENOUGH FROM ME, BIG
TRUST.
AND THAT'S ENOUGH FOR YOU ALL.
I APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
THERE'S NOTHING THAT I COULD
TELL YOU THATI YOU COULDN'T SEE
FROM THE BALTIMORE RAVENS.
NOW I HAVE TO PREPARE FOR THE
CHARGERS.
NOW JUSTIN HERBERT OR AS I LIKE
TO CALL HIM BY HIS FRENCH NAME,
JUSTIN HEBERT IS COMING INTO MY
TOWN IN THEIR FANCY POWDER BLUES
AND THEY EXPECT TO WIN?
GUESS WHAT, SLEEPYHEADS?
THE GAME'S AT 10:00 A.M. YOUR
TIME, AND LAMAR JACKSON -- WHY
HE HAS NEVER SLEPT.
LAMAR JACKSON, OUT.
>> NOW LET'S CHECK IN ON DAN
CAMPBELL.
FOOTBALL HAS BETRAYED ME!
♪